good day everyone and welcome I'm Jack
Van Horn from the University of Virginia
and I am very proud to welcome you to
this edition of our
2022-2023 foundations of biomedical data
science seminar Series this lecture
series is supported by uva's integrated
translational Health Institute of
Virginia the UVA brain Institute the
College of Arts and Sciences the school
of data science and through grants from
the National Institutes of General
Medical Sciences since 2016 the
foundations of biomedical data science
seminar Series has focused on the use of
data science methodologies artificial
intelligence deep learning and
statistical modeling as they pertain to
different themes in the biomedical and
Health Sciences this year's chosen theme
is data science and the public health
consequences of the covid-19 pandemic
where each Friday we will enjoy
presentations from leading thinkers
about the issues the promise the
opportunities and the hurdles associated
with understanding the secondary health
effects of covet 19. these include
delayed Health checkups and treatments
mental health drug abuse increased
obesity and the long lingering health
effects associated with the SARS
covid-19 virus participants selected for
our biomedical data science Innovation
lab program will leverage these
presentations as vital material for our
culminating in-person Grant development
Workshop to be held at the lodge at St
Edwards Park in Seattle Washington in
June of 2023. today I am delighted to
welcome our speaker Dr Christopher
Murray who is the chair of the health
metric Sciences at the University of
Washington and the director of The
Institute for health metrics and
evaluation he holds his MD from Harvard
he has a d Mill from Oxford and he did
his undergraduate work also at Harvard
his career has focused on the impro on
improving population Health worldwide
through better evidence he is a
physician and health Economist and work
has led to the development of innovative
methods to strengthen Health measurement
analyze the performance of Health
Systems understand the drivers of health
and to produce forecasts of the future
states of Health a in continuing with
our 2022-2023 biomedical data science
seminar series Chris's theme today is
inter talk today is entitled how well
did the world do modeling covid Dr
Murray will describe how he and his team
search the body of covid-19 modeling
globally from the start of the pandemic
and reviewed over 7 000 different models
and articles and websites of these a
number of them had available data and
then they were able to evaluate the
performance of these models against what
happened during the pandemic using
performance measures that included
forecasting skill they were able to draw
a number of different conclusions which
Chris is going to summarize for us and
he's going to make some recommendations
on how we can do a better job in the
future and share some lessons learned
about how to validate models and Global
Health more broadly as always we are
streaming this lecture live and for
recording via YouTube and if you are
watching on YouTube thank you so much
for joining us also our specially
selected 2022-2023 biomedical data
science Innovation lab participants and
alumni are Inc encouraged to submit any
questions they have by the chat feature
in their Zoom sessions I will synthesize
these questions and ask them on your
behalf during the last 10 minutes or so
of the lecture and with that welcome Dr
Murray we are super excited to hear from
you today
thank you very much happy to be here uh
so I'm going to talk about our effort to
look at
the sort of infectious disease modeling
Community response to covid uh we were
part of that community that responded
and and participated as one of the
modeling groups uh the many modeling
groups out there and model covid really
from March 2020 on our part right
through till January of this year
so this is a perspective both of looking
at all the published and other models
out there and also one from having tried
to do this
um so as you may or may not know there
was quite a response from the modeling
Community to the pandemic uh in this
country and in many other countries
uh by uh we we I won't go into the sort
of systematic review part of this of
trying to find a republished study uh
try to contact all the groups that
contributed to the cdc-led modeling
Ensemble Hub and the European Hub and
all the other efforts we also look tried
to reach out to different governments
and ask them Which models they used and
in some cases obtained
modeling efforts that weren't published
or in the public domain
we have found meeting our inclusion
criteria for models which was at least
five efforts so there's some a number of
one-offs that we found and didn't really
spend time evaluating but groups that
made at least five uh five releases of
their model we included and we end up
with more than 300 that meet that
criteria
now I'm gonna
take a large diversion into uh how we
should or should not evaluate
performance of modeling because I think
if I don't do that then the conclusions
on covid are are somewhat shaky
and uh interestingly uh the the
Infectious Disease modeling Community
historically has not paid much attention
to their performance in forecasting uh
as opposed to other disciplines that I'm
going to draw on like weather climate
and economics so uh the diversion will
begin with trying to go back on the
history of thinking about forecasting
both philosophically and quantitatively
look at various the sort of major themes
of forecasts evaluation
look at another case namely the imf's
effort to predict income and then dive
into the results of looking at all the
covet models
um and then round out with
General observations about how we might
do a better job
as a spoiler alert I think the key theme
of this is the Infectious Disease
modeling community did a very bad job
but let me try to carry you along with
that
so first uh forecasting has been around
a long time there's books on on
forecasting there's a nice book on the
history of economic forecasting going
back to even the 1890s but there was
really quite a lot of technical
discussion about how does one evaluate
forecasting uh in the 1930s even Keynes
commented on this and there's a paper by
Tim Bergen in 1939 on more quantitative
thinking about evaluating forecasts
so this is uh not new terrain we have
intellectually an 80-year history of a
forecast evaluation it's that history
just has not made it into much some
there's some exceptions into the
Infectious Disease modeling worlds
perhaps the most sophisticated in terms
of the use of uh routine evaluation of
forecasts is the weather community
and I will come back to that over and
over just how we can learn a lot from
the way the scientific Community around
weather forecasting and even the World
Meteorological organization's efforts to
encourage uh standardized metrics for
for evaluation of forecasts
I'm going to emphasize whether an
economic forecasting but many fields
Sports forecasting agriculture others
use forecasts and evaluate those
forecasts and with a little a few
exceptions there's a flu group that did
has done some forecast evaluation in the
past and then a coveted modeling
Ensemble that used one particular
approach to forecast evaluation uh
there's very little of this in the
Infectious Disease world
now I'm going to end up showing you
skill metrics because uh the modeling
the forecast community
in whether climate economics and others
have uh tended towards since the 1980s
measures that are called skill which is
for a given error metric how you
evaluate you know how good your forecast
is
comparing it to a very simple Baseline
model then can give you a zero one
scaled metric which is very attractive
because then you don't get caught up in
what does it mean at .032 of a root mean
squared error for one thing and a six in
another space they're not comparable
numbers whereas skill is really quite
comparable because it's formulated as
one minus the error of your your
favorite error metric for your model
divided by the error of us of a
particular Baseline model for for
weather that's super easy because the
Baseline model is the historic average
of the weather tomorrow
uh from quantological data
or economic forecasting its historic
growth rates and so you can go along
those lines and when we come to covet
it'll be an interesting question of what
is the simple Baseline model
skills not only useful as a way of
thinking about measuring forecast
performance but it is also handy to
address the question of the skill
Horizon when does skill go to zero
compared to a very simple Baseline model
uh in weather that's in about two weeks
uh it's been getting longer and longer
as modeling has gotten better uh and in
economic forecasting it's it's
um you know a number of years into the
future and the big question that's still
outstanding on covid is what is the
skill Horizon for for infectious disease
or for coping modeling
now there is a philosophical issue that
comes up a lot it came up in the
literature around economic forecasting
right back in the 30s and 40s
uh and you hear it a lot around coven
and that is if my audience is the
government
and I model out what I think is going to
happen in the future and then the
government uses my model to because I
provide both a forecast and some
alternative scenarios and I persuade the
government to change policy let's say
adopt mask use have a mask mandate
uh then I shouldn't be held accountable
for uh the successful use of my model to
change policy
and it's very interesting I think the
most sophisticated treatment of this
philosophical issue is from the
organization of economic cooperation
development oecd which is uh you know
basically the high income economies uh
that belong to the oecd and they do a
lot of income forecasting and I think
Way Back 40 years ago they framed that
if you are only modeling for government
and it's not publicly available and
nobody is taking an action based on that
then that argument might hold true that
maybe you should have a conditional
assessment
of what happened conditional on in your
model of what was the policy regime the
government adopted
but their argument was that in fact
almost always think the Federal Reserve
on inflation or the Federal Reserve on
GDP growth uh or the IMF on GDP growth
uh these forecasts are not just for
government they get into the public
space and many private actors companies
individuals take action based on them
and therefore while in theory your
forecast may change policy you as a
forecaster should be accountable if the
public knows about the forecast for also
predicting how individuals and and
governments will re will act and so that
should be part and parcel of the
forecasting business and therefore we
should be able
to and and want to report on forecast
skill and any metric you would like
we'll probably come back in Q a to this
sort of philosophical question
now the economists uh are very focused
as are some other fields geophysics for
example uh on measures of accuracy how
well does your forecasts the mean
estimate of your forecast or the point
estimate compared to what actually
happened
and many economic forecasts to this day
do not provide uncertainty they just say
we think the most likely growth rate for
the U.S economy in the next quarter is
you know 1.2 percent what and and uh
there there is some growth of
probabilistic forecasting but not a lot
is still dominated by Point estimates
because that's actually what most
decision makers act on
um and we'll again a big philosophical
debate about how important is
uncertainty and we'll come back to that
here's a review of economic forecasting
that was published in 2022 by budarak of
just going through in a systematic
review of all the different error
metrics used
in
um the
um economic forecasting world
and divided started into two large
buckets
metrics that are in the units of
whatever you care about and just usually
growth rates uh you know the absolute
error of various types in growth rates
and then metrics that refer to some
version of relative error whether it's
percents or ratios or even somewhat more
complex measures as shown here
so same issue will come up with covet
now another area just to get to how
messy this whole metric space is is in
here's a paper in 2021 of a huge range
of metrics uh in limon's paper uh used
in geophysics uh model performance
assessment and so that's you know
there's a wide array
um many of them overlapping with what's
in the economics literature now there's
a way to capture many but not all of
those measures
uh in a general family of error metrics
where you take the absolute value shown
here as you know absolute value of y
minus y hat uh in the numerator and
raise that to a power Alpha
that then encompasses people who are
interested in mean absolute error or
mean squared error Alpha being one or
two
and then in the denominator you can
capture this issue of absolute error
versus relative error by dividing by y
to avoid the situation where you divide
by zero you put a little number called
Epsilon in there just to avoid the
problem the possibility of dividing by
zero
and then you raise that absolute value
to Beta where beta is one your these are
measures of relative error beta is zero
these are measures of absolute error and
anything in between
now the last little bit of this is Theta
which is uh the notion to make the
results
um uh robust to outliers because these
error measures particularly when Alpha
gets greater than one
doing a bad forecast in one week for one
location can make your overall error
look terrible and I will show this for
covid uh and so the Theta term here is
to uh quote windsorize the the error
function so that if your error is above
some value Theta you uh don't keep
making that contribution to the overall
error measure uh larger and larger now
it's easier to see this in a visual
so if you think about an arametric uh
this is true for you know you know in a
likelihood function but just in terms of
these performance metrics you can think
of it uh visualize these different
approaches by showing the absolute value
of the error on the x-axis and the loss
that you're going to calculate on the
y-axis
and you know mean squared error is the
green line
as you a loss uh a error of two gets a
loss of four the square
uh and a linear one is the light green
line where an error of two gets a weight
of two in the loss function so you can
see that in the difference between the
squared error and the linear of course
is that you are really saying I don't
want to make large errors in the case of
covid that large errors are much worse
than a series of smaller errors
uh now the winds are rising says at in
this case at the value of two you are
going to hold the loss at a flat line
and so you get the gray line for a
windsorized loss function and if common
measure the one that we use a lot and I
will show you is windsoride root mean
squared error where you windsorize the
error at some percentile of The observed
absolute error we often use 95 so once
you're above the 95th percentile of
error you get the same you know bad
weight it's not getting worse and worse
and worse and I'll show you why this
turns out to be important now there's a
group out there that uh I don't think is
relevant to covid that actually want to
have a concave loss function shown where
an alpha is less than one uh and there
are certain applications out there where
that might be interesting
um but it is an unusual uh shape
now in weather in contrast to economic
forecasting forecasts are mostly
probabilistic and so there's a different
set of metrics that have emerged uh for
predicting you know what's the
probability of rain tomorrow
and these go back to the 1950s there's
again a huge array of these measures the
main ones are listed here reliability
measures uh coverage versus accuracy
plot where you know you count how in
your 95 uncertain interval what percent
of the time the truth or the future
shows up in that interval uh and I'll
give a little bit more detail about
Briar scores ranked probability scores
and then continuous rank probability
scores
so using some concrete results here is
the UK Met Office plot of reliability
and this is for their
um
mid-term six month out forecasts
uh or actually you know two to four
months out forecasts of whether the
temperature will be higher than equal to
or less than a climatological averages
so it's it's for weather this is long
range rough forecasting and on the
x-axis they show the probability of
being in those three buckets
and on the y-axis they show The observed
probability so if you take all the
forecasts to 50 percent
what was the the uh frequency and
reality of being above uh in the case of
the red line of being above normal
temperature
and you want your model to be on the 45
degree line right and the fact that
these weather forecasts uh when the
probability is low the truth is higher
and when the probability is high the
truth is lower points to the lack of
reliability of the forecast which is
worse for being in the middle and
slightly better for being predicting too
hot or too low too too cold
another way of using the same forecasts
again using the UK Med office example is
to use an Roc curve these are receiver
operating curves I'm sure most of you
are familiar with these
um for predicting a dichotomous outcome
you have the false positive rate and the
true positive rate uh at false positive
on X true on Y and you want to be up on
the top left corner and then the ROC you
can integrate the area between the Curve
uh and a 45 degree line
to get in a a summary measure of that
and again you can see this difference in
performance for predicting high and low
versus predicting in the middle
interestingly the weather communities is
sophisticated enough that they compute
these metrics whatever they're looking
at whether it's weather or mid-range or
climate uh by location and they produce
maps showing you where models did worse
or better so the dark Reds are where
they're doing well
uh and the blues are where they're doing
poorly and out over the oceans they seem
to do rather well whereas they do not as
well uh in a number of land masses
other probability measures uh Brier in
1950 came up with very simple idea of
taking the predicted probability of an
outcome
minus the observed which is either zero
or one of an outcome let's say rain more
than two millimeters and then just you
know squaring that and then adding that
up across all your predictions dividing
it and you get
um you know uh the Briar score which is
actually still widely used
there's a version of the prior score
where you have a a polygamous prediction
you know
um think of in covid uh the analog would
be predicting covet incidence is low
medium high very high you can calculate
your buyer score for each of those
categories and then sum up over
categories and over time and you get a
ranked probability score
and then the final version of this is uh
the continuous rank probability score
where your uh you have a continuous
curve a prediction the red line and then
the actual observed probability of the
event is the blue line and you compute
the red area between your cumulative
probability distribution of the
prediction for y uh compared to what was
observed for y
now the the there's a key distinction
here which is sensitivity to outliers
which in the case of code it's going to
turn out to be super important
if you use a continuous probably uh rank
score you are very sensitive to Crazy
outliers let's say you made a really bad
job one week and your model went crazy
and you predicted a massive epidemic and
it didn't occur in one place that can
swamp your overall CRPS whereas in the
rank probability score here if you set
the Threshold at some level you say you
know I'm interested if I predicted very
high but I'm going to give the same
weight
to the loss of predicting very high and
and absolutely insane it the RPS as the
same thing as windsorizing on the
accuracy measures then builds in some
resistance to uh the extreme outliers
buddy that the weather Community
routinely like every week uh depend on
for most models is reporting their skill
and they're not only reporting skill but
they're comparing their skill to the
main competitors they have and in the
weather world because weather models are
really quite complex
um
there's not that many models that are
modeling for the world
and you know most of them are listed
here and you get pretty routine uh uh
assessments of skill
okay so that's some background history
on skill and the metrics and now we're
going to turn to two cases one very
quickly on income
uh because I think in something's
important is a super complicated task
because human behavior and the policy
response matters a lot for predicting
income and then uh we'll turn to covet
and the reason I want to show income is
that I too often hear from the
Infectious Disease modeling Community oh
it's too hard that's why we do so badly
uh but in fact you know if you think
about the complexity of economies they
are super complex entities and with an
enormous amount of individual Behavior
response as well as policy response
so I'm now comparing two measures of
skill for IMF forecasts over the last 25
years so ever twice a year the uh the
international monetary fund predicts the
next five years economic growth
for every country in the world and so
there's a nice time series of their
forecasts they're all publicly available
you can go play with them yourself and
they have two they predict many
indicators that the one I'm focusing on
here is GDP growth rates and they
predict them both in what are called
constant dollars on the left which is
after correcting for inflation and they
predict nominal dollars actual dollars
that you you go and spend which are
called current prices which you include
economic growth and inflation
and what we're seeing here is a
comparison of just two skill measures
the skill measure on the x-axis is uh
windsorized
um root mean square error and on the
y-axis is without the windsoring
so just to show that skill once you wins
your eyes for a number of
the predictions uh is better because you
are not uh taking the two or three
countries they do a terrible job on uh
and really you know having that drive
the overall assessment to give you some
examples in other modeling that we do
completely unrelated covid uh we get not
uncommonly an example of where one
modeling strategy in 99 of the cases
gives you uh smaller you know better
accuracy but in one percent of the cases
worse and that one percent is large
enough that the summary measure of root
mean squared error is worse even though
the model is better 99 of the time
whereas in the windsorized measure uh
you take away that and it sort of
Accords more to your intuition that if
you're doing better in 99 of the cases
uh your summary measure will look better
here's another comparison again for
skill skill on the x-axis here is just
what we were showing windsorized root
mean squared error and on the y-axis is
now a relative measure and it's just to
point out that there's very little
relationship between skill predicting
the absolute GDP growth rate versus the
percent error or the relative uh error
in the growth rate and that's often
because when you have a small growth
rate like 0.1 percent and you predict
0.3 percent well that's a 200 error and
that looks really bad at those measures
so not some people have uses for
relative measures but they're very
unusual and have unusual properties
so fine last slide before we moved to
covid uh which is how good is the IMF at
predicting well for constant prices and
and here I'm comparing two Baseline
models a baseline model that just says
GDP growth rate will stay will be zero
into the future which is a sort of not a
great model uh and then the four-year
historical average uh growth rate is
what you predict into the future
and for uh current prices on the right
hand side
that model the Baseline model of a
four-year growth rate then IMF forecasts
have
you know skill of 0.4 in the first three
months dropping down to a skill that's
around 0.15 on a zero one scale and then
interestingly sort of increasing over
time uh going up to a scale of about
0.25 by five year five five years 60
months
if you have a really bad Baseline model
uh namely that the economies on average
will not grow at all which historically
is not the case shown in blue then you
make the skill of their models look
better and this is a little bit of a
game that exists in these forecast skill
World which is if you pick a really
bad Baseline model you can make your
skill look better so just a a warning
there
on the left hand side
skill is much worse once you get past
you know a one year down below 0.1 uh
and that's because it's in constant
prices so now on the left you have to
predict both inflation and GDP growth so
the difference between the two means
that the IMF has been historically
better higher skill at predicting what's
going to happen in nominal dollars less
good at dividing that future growth into
what's inflation versus not
okay
let's go to code let's start with
reliability
and I'm going to show these plots in
some cases for U.S models
and for all other locations combined
for reliability I'm just going to uh
I'll do the same thing uh here so for
reliability these are all models about
80 of them uh and combined
and what is their reliability so you
take all the predictions of being above
a certain threshold this is for
predictions at the death rate from covid
and you can see if the threshold is how
well do I predict the death rate
being uh over let's say three three per
hundred thousand uh which by the way is
not a
um
particularly low death rate but still
then you can see there's almost no
information content in the forecasts in
aggregate because it's a flat line and
it should be on the 45 degree line so I
predict 50 being above three and what I
observe is in during the the pandemic
was uh for those forecasts that you know
95 you're above three so lots and lots
of forecasts that were too low
as well if you look at the Orange Line
of 180 per hundred thousand uh when I
predict or not that when the modeling
community on average predicts eighty
percent chance of being at a high level
huge level 180 per hundred thousand The
observed probability is about 60 percent
so over predicting really high surges
and this has been a characteristic of
some of the models throughout the
pandemic
here's the same graph for non-us
locations
and it looks a little better actually
but in general the slope instead of
being 45 degrees uh is actually quite
flat
and the flatter these lines are the less
information content there is in the
prediction so one if you were to compare
this to the reliability plot we saw for
you know three to six months forecasts
of temperature uh certainly not doing as
well as as those
now we're going to go on to skill
various types and uh the question of
course is the Baseline model you saw how
the choice of the Baseline makes a
difference for uh you know income uh
forecasting and so for covid what we
picked is a baseline And I think others
have as well in like the CDC Ensemble uh
uh efforts at looking at skill
is covet staying constant from the last
measurement just hold it constant so
it's a super simplistic model so you
would have hoped that we would the the
modeling Community would easily beat
that
now
skill uh the the relationship of skill
will matter
if you do or do not take into account
the outliers and this is one way to
visualize that I'm showing windsorized
skill
at windsorizing at the 95th percentile
of the difference between Y and Y hat
in this case the code death rate versus
just the root mean squared error of of
the death rate and uh obviously the
remain squared error is worse and skill
is worse when you use that because you
were affected by outliers but it has a
huge pretty large effect in in the case
of skill
and here's another comparison this is
CRPS skill which is outlier sensitive
and then windsorized skills looking only
at accuracy remember CRPS is sort of a
joint measure of uncertainty and
accuracy
and important to note that skill in
those two two different metrics
um is really quite different so you have
positive skill for CRPS that can have
negative win through our skill so just
to note that and vice versa
okay
so let's go start with basic uh here's
graphs for modeling efforts throughout
the pandemic so just everything that's
been done we're talking actually
millions of forecasts across the
different groups by week and week out
lump them all together uh put forecast
week into the future on the x-axis
and inside and outside the US uh and
basically on average
the modeling community
has had negative skill so we're not
talking about you know a skilled
0.2.4.6.8 we're saying that we were
worse than a flatline forecast so this
is a what I would describe as a massive
fail for the Infectious Disease modeling
community
however
if you go to windsorized skill
where you say okay we're not going to
have the overall judgment be driven by
the crazy forecast you made for one
state in the U.S or one country in in
Africa or wherever that something just
went wildly wrong You released a
forecast that was you know impossible
but and that throws off those metrics
Because by the way lots of modeling
groups did do that they just didn't have
the quality control to even stop on the
releasing things where something had
clearly gone wildly wrong
so if you give people the benefit of the
doubt sense and windsori's skill then
you get a less depressing picture but
still pretty poor
namely unlike weather and economic
forecasting where you get the classic
curve or skill is greatest one week out
or one unit of time out you know one
year or one day one week uh and then
declines towards zero and you get to the
skill Horizon we see the opposite
relationship in the U.S where skill was
worse than a flatline forecast out to
about three weeks then actually becomes
positive and uh goes up and stays
positive and you see this bump at 15
weeks and this is compositional bias
that namely the modeling groups that did
longer range forecasts on average had
better skill
so as you go far more and more weeks out
on this graph you're getting to that
subset of modeling groups that that
actually fared better
and that's why skill bumps up at 15
weeks
same story for outside the U.S you had
negative scale out to 14 weeks uh and
then you get you know a little bit of
skill at the tail end
now what about the relationship between
coverage doing a good job on uncertainty
for covet and accuracy doing a good job
on the point estimate and this shows you
for each modeling group
or across whatever they modeled
throughout the pandemic uh windsorized
its skill on the x-axis and coverage of
the uncertain intervals on y
you want the coverage of your 95
uncertain renewable to be 0.95 so you
want to be at 0.95 on the y-axis and you
want to be as far out on the right hand
side as you can be on for skill and uh
several observations here first there's
no relationship between coverage and
accuracy
so it's not the case uh in general that
those that had more accurate models uh
had better on certain intervals they're
just sort of unrelated Dimensions here
um secondly there's a cluster of models
up in the top right that had for short
range forecasts one two three weeks uh
you know good coverage and skill of
about 0.25 and those it turns out tend
to be models that are in those cases for
one location so there's a little cluster
of modeling groups that did forecasts
for one location and they did a good job
in both dimensions
and then there's a call you know there's
these uh as you can tell by the colors
some of the groups that do long range
forecasting including ourselves down
here on the bottom right uh with you
know moderate
um skill and but uncertain intervals
were were too small and we'll come back
to calibration at the end of this
presentation
what about
um
the question of did we learn as a
community to do a better job during the
pandemic
so here's skill
during the course of the pandemic so now
the x-axis is calendar week
and there's no indication here that as a
community the Infectious Disease
modeling Community including you know
extreme errors did a better job over
time so what about for windsorized skill
and in the U.S you can see that there
were periods where skill went up
for example in the period in this in the
sort of
um you know April May June of 2021
before Delta hit most places and then
when Delta hit still dropped way down
because people didn't anticipate it the
red line dips
similar story uh as we get into 2022
where there was uh you know a drop in
skill as Omicron came on board models
adjusted skill went back up and then ba5
came along
uh and subsequent waves of Omicron and
skill got dramatically worse
so overall both in the U.S and out no
clear signal that the community learned
to do a better job
here's a a dynamic map of skill by
location
and what's interesting here is to
regardless of the week out
uh modeling all models participating and
I'll let it play again uh did a really
poor job for sub-Saharan Africa
and a very poor job in East and
Southeast Asia with the exception of
Malaysia
and then you get this phenomenon that
skill goes up towards the end and again
that's compositional bias where this the
small set of groups that do the longer
range forecasting on average had higher
scale
okay so rather depressing if you're in
in infectious disease modeling as as we
are uh so what conclusions can we draw
from all this
so first off many modeling groups
struggled with the fundamental data they
were fitting their models to they did
not have the resources or perhaps time
or inclination or skill set to do the
Deep dive into the data to make sense of
it and they ended up
um you know reflecting in their models
really crazy data errors that were in
the real time of the pandemic being
released and not being caught and being
dealt with
um and that's true both for the outcomes
incidents you know reported cases
hospitalizations deaths but also for all
the variables that might go into a model
uh such as social distancing or mass use
in the other
the other thing that many groups did on
the data front was because they didn't
have the time or the energy to go into
the details of the data uh they made you
know extreme assumptions that the
infection detection rate remain constant
for example the Department of Defense
had a whole modeling effort throughout
the first year of the pandemic where
they assumed that the infection
detection rate was 100 percent
uh and of course they knew it was not
but they just didn't have the strategy
to to deal with that
um so you know at our end we developed
an attempt to triangulate
using
cases Hospital admissions deaths
and the zero prevalence data shown on
the right in the purple dots uh
corrected for various biases in it to
try to in in real time compute each week
what some of these key parameters were
like the the infection detection rate
the infection hospitalization rate and
the infection fatality rate and how they
were changing and that turned out to be
super important at least from our view
of sort of that data triangulation
effort uh and yet we had huge Divergence
across modeling groups on some of the
basics like the IFR the ihr or the IDR
another basic Insight is that uh many
modeling groups stood up you know
stepped up to the challenge
they said you know I'm an infectious
disease modeler or I'm a modeler in
general I'm a data scientist uh this is
a national Global crisis you know I'm
going to throw my hat in the ring and
participate which was great to see
people step up and try to help uh but
many of those models were simple seir
models uh you know in the in the classic
susceptible exposed infected recovered I
know ordinary differential equation box
models
and they used simple fixed parameters
like are not
um and uh then never change their model
despite all the learning during the
pandemic and the role of variants the
role of vaccination the role of
antivirals the role of seasonality the
role of human behavior the role of mass
use and the like and so you know
incredible
um
you know uh focus on a simplistic model
and not changing
most models the vast vast majority over
95 percent made no attempt to build into
their models human behavioral response
you know social distancing and mask use
for example when things got bad
nor did they explicitly try to model how
governments would respond when things
got out of control
and I can give you many anecdotes having
talked to many sort of political leaders
during the pandemic of modeling groups
advising them with these very strange
you know
um uh you know assumptions that were
leading to extreme conclusions and
extreme requests for resources earlier
in pandemic and when you ask modeling
groups why their response was oh you
know we don't know how or it's out of
scope or we just don't really know how
to deal with behavior and policy
perhaps the most damning I think is the
culture of not reporting skill
you know however you want to measure
Windsor High School whatever your
favorite measure of skill there is no
culture in the Infectious Disease
modeling world of doing this there's
some bright exceptions the CDC modeling
Ensemble which was only for short run
forecasts four weeks but nevertheless
they did periodically try to look at
skills so that's a bright spot in this
story but in general the Infectious
Disease modeling Community resists the
routine reporting of skill uh and in my
view we will never see better
performance from infectious disease
modeling uh for forecasting purposes
unless we adopt what other fields do
which is a culture of routine real-time
reporting around scale
bizarrely as a reflection of not looking
at skill modeling efforts that had
negative skill throughout the pandemic
kept going
so you had groups that were notably
worse than a flatline forecast that just
kept making forecasts
and
um
you know that that doesn't happen in
other fields if you think about sports
forecasting and what bookies do
oddsmakers do uh they will lose money if
they did that and so there's a
self-correcting mechanism in that
community and in income forecasting and
weather forecasting there is a culture
of routine reporting so really bad
modeling efforts do tend to drop out
pretty quickly
now a little side note uh we shouldn't
be too harsh on the folks that uh
stepped up and tried and did a bad job
uh at least they tried but there's a
whole group of modeling and some very
very accomplished well-known infectious
disease modeling groups that never made
forecasts they were pundits on the
sideline and they would criticize
forecasts but never made their own and I
think it's a pretty simple diagnostic
there they never made forecasts because
they were worried about having poor
skill and didn't want to expose
themselves to that sort of
um critique publicly but it is curious
that you know if not for covid when
would you ever step up and do uh
forecasting
another thing that I think we have not
learned from the weather Community uh is
that there's a very simple post-hop fix
used in the weather Community to fix
poor coverage of
um model predictions or to fix
reliability
which is they routinely look at their
model performance in the last period of
time and say if I predicted rain 60 of
the time and I only observe rain 50
percent of the time then I post hoc take
my model prediction of 60 and call it 50
percent
and that post-hoc calibration improves
performance and it's a pretty simple
device that we could import into
infectious disease modeling or covet
modeling or whatever else comes down the
pike uh so that we both get the
uncertain intervals to be accurate and
also could shift the mean of those
predictions uh or the the point estimate
to get on the 45 degree line
there's you pay us you pay a price for
calibration which is you become less
capable uh but true of predicting you
know either end zero probability or 100
probability but for covert modeling
that's almost never the case right
nobody's ever been that great you know
we haven't seen skill up above you know
on average about a 0.25 or a 0.3
so my last slide here and then we'll
have some q a uh is what do we do in the
future and we could ask this question a
lot and I think my view of the strategy
is sort of threefold one
uh as in the weather world uh we're
probably all better off if there are 10
modeling groups that are
um that have demonstrably good you know
positive skill that you try to build
them up and have them commit to routine
and real-time reporting of skills so
they compete during the process of an
epidemic to get better and learn from
each other and if you never will as we
saw during covet if you don't do that
but the idea that we'll have hundreds of
modeling groups with good skills seems
hard to do given all the work that needs
to go into keeping up with a disease as
it involves
secondly a lot of the problems and
models do Trace back to lack of data or
or the cost of acquiring some of the
critical data points and part of that is
governments themselves us being an
example were reluctant or very slow to
release data and there's many reasons
behind that
um you know some of the analysts within
CDC wanting to publish papers before the
other people see the data some worried
about the public misinterpretation of
the data a long list but bottom line is
we're all safer and better off if there
is a commitment to release the relevant
data in a very short time period
and lastly I think and this is a little
bit more questionable because I don't
have proof of it
but part of the problem of why modeling
groups did not adapt to the virus as a
change you know adding vaccination add
in antivirals add in Waiting immunity
which is quite complex is that those
make models much more complex and harder
to converge and require a certain you
know both access to computation a
certain set of skills and it might be
the case for those of the models and for
machine learning models uh that having
some uh standardized tools that have
those capabilities built in that are
widely shared open source and could then
be changed and adapted by different
groups because you don't want everybody
to have the same model uh I think you
know that's certainly not what other
communities do to to do a better job
they have large ensembles
of quite different models but you still
need to help groups get over the hurdle
of the resist of the challenge of
incorporating some of these more complex
phenomena like waning immunity
so those are some Reflections on how we
might do better next time around uh
given what I'll have to confess is a
rather depressing story of how the
modeling Community stepped up for the
code 19 pandemic
foreign thank you so much I'm filled
with questions
um one of the things you showed a slide
early in your talk which was all the
different types of kind of cost
functions that people evaluated their
metrics with respect to
um usually some sort of ratio of signal
to noise in however you want to Define
that what question is that people I
presume make a choice of what they want
the denominator of their Baseline model
error to be or rather it's basically
derived from their model is that seemed
a little bit it seems like it would be
difficult to compare across models
because they don't share a common
denominator and so that skill metric is
sort of skill with respect to that
particular model but it still you know
doesn't have a common denominator is is
that is that perception correct
no I don't think so I think the the
Baseline model which is you know what
you have to you have to have the error
for your Baseline model to uh calculate
skill uh you know if for example all the
Kobe comparisons it's the exact same
Baseline it's that covet stays flat okay
so as long as the Baseline is the same
thing then then for a given skill metric
rmsc mean squared or whatever you want
CRPS then that that's the beauty of
skill it is comparable okay uh is a
skill comparing uh weather skill zero
one of you know whether compared to
climatological average comparable to a
covet model compared to a flatline model
uh yes no you know I think as long as
you pick the Baseline to be the the the
best simple Baseline for that field I
think in some sense you're still
incomparable how much better are you
than a very naive model
in the case of kobit you might come
along in the future as say uh you know
Flatline is a little extreme it's too
simple and so in fact we're we're
skewing towards making the models look
good by picking a very simplistic
Baseline but already we look so bad that
you know I'm not sure that gets us off
the hook
are there any um attempts to like look
at me more information theoretical
metrics such as you know KL Divergence
or other things that try to uh work
directly on the the probabilities uh
from an information theoretical point of
view
there are you know there's there's an
information Theory
um justification if you will for the the
CRPS The Continuous rank probability
score there are some other measures like
teals measure that are you know are
grounded in information Theory
um so there's a there are a number of uh
error metrics where people have tried to
link to uh information theory in some
way
are there any evolutionary approaches to
this where you sort of mentioned you
know skill which is I suppose one metric
of overall performance but if even skill
isn't working out very well is there
something like model Fitness that would
allow you to say okay in this generation
of the model run or whatever it is that
that it did a good job therefore it
lives on those that don't do well then
fallouts and they are they basically go
extinct
um is there any sort of movement towards
that that would help
no and in fact that's you know it's it's
another way of framing what I'm calling
for which is you would hope if there was
as in weather routine
prediction a reporting of skill that bad
models would drop out right and we did
not see that at all yeah I mean you
commented on that you know models that
were doing poorly just kept reporting
poor numbers and they did not just go by
the wayside you know from an
evolutionary point of view that the the
ones with the best fitness should have
continued to the Next Generation and
those that didn't die off uh were still
kind of around
no we we saw no shift uh and I guess
that graph of skill over calendar week
is the most
you know depressing in a sense that uh
as an academic Community
um you know not to point fingers at any
one group but as a group as the totality
of the Infectious modeling community no
self-realization no Evolution towards
better models
as we have a group of new newly minted
faculty members of Many Times building
their research networks and starting
their careers uh working in this space
what sort of advice do you have as they
get started
you know I I think it applies uh this
notion of skill
applies not just to forecasting but just
to prediction in general
um you know uh you know some people call
it forecasting or now casting whatever
you want to call it and I just think
it's very painful right for the modeling
groups to look at their performance uh
because it's very easy to if you don't
look at the metrics especially skill
metrics uh it's very easy to delude
yourself for some reason that you know
things are going well and so I think
it's the it's the discipline of looking
at some measure of skill
and saying wait because everyone well
not everyone we people in our Fields
love complexity right uh love to come up
with whether machine learning or
Bayesian statistical uh models you know
Revel in complexity and it's it's a good
discipline to say hold on a second does
the more complicated approach
actually give me better forecasts and
when you have numbers that are where the
scale is sort of incomparable and
meaningless it's very easy to miss the
fact that you may not have skill over
something like a flatline model which is
a pretty low bar to get to so just that
that you know intellectual honesty with
yourself is super is a good discipline
to adopt
do you think that there's a case for
parsimony here you mentioned like the
level of complexity
um you know people always like to go for
the more what you know is maybe trendy
or apparently more sophisticated but
maybe sometimes simple is better
sometimes I think it's a very tricky
walk a road to walk because sometimes
Simplicity is not better because some
phenomena are truly complex but
sometimes uh Simplicity is better and I
I
like you know I I uh tell my junior
faculty here that are working on these
sort of issues uh they they do tend to
fall into lumpers and Splitters right
there's a group of people who just see
any results or problem and think of the
ways in which more complexity will uh
enhance the the assessment
and then we have the reverse phenomena
people who really like to go for
Simplicity and it's sort of getting that
balance right and I think the only way
we can do that is with you know Guided
by some sort of metrics
well Chris thank you so much for sharing
this work with us and lots of food for
thought about how we kind of evaluate
these models their their ability to
successfully forecast things and how we
can measure that ability
um and I hope that we've learned
something out of this you know last
couple of years where we were really
tested to kind of do this real time and
to find models that were effective and
hopefully we've learned a thing or two
and it sounds like you and your team are
at the tip of that spear so thank you so
much for for sharing this with us
um I want to thank everybody who joined
us here on zoom and out on YouTube and
uh wish everyone a wonderful weekend and
uh we'll see you later bye everybody
thank you cheers thank you Chris